a Kentucky Commission has voted to take
down a statue of Confederate President
Jefferson Davis from the State Capitol
it's part of a nationwide push to remove
symbols of racism and slavery and comes
in the heels of new legislation in
Louisville it bans police from entering
a suspects home without first
identifying themselves the law was named
Briana's law for Brianna Taylor who was
mistakenly gunned down by police back in
March
Jericka Duncan reports after heated
protests and emotional pleas Louisville
Mayor Greg Fischer signed
Briana's law under the new law police
will no longer be able to enter a
suspects home without announcing who
they are and they must wear body cameras
Taylor's mother Tameka Palmer it means
it was nearly three months ago March
13th
that police used a battering ram to
enter Taylor's apartment after midnight
believing it was being used by a drug
dealer to receive packages while the
plainclothes officers contend they
identify themselves Taylor's boyfriend
says they did not and he opened fire to
defend himself against what he thought
were intruders he later called 911 in
his arms after she was shot by police at
least eight times can you get her turned
over on her back there's been a dramatic
increase in the use of no-knock warrants
over the last 40 years mainly for
drug-related crimes with a nearly 7,000
percent increase sets Downton is a law
professor at the University of South
Carolina if officers aren't knocking and
announcing the individuals inside may
not know who is breaking down their door
which creates potential for error the
three officers involved in the shooting
death of Taylor have been put on
administrative leave while the
investigation is pending this week
authorities released a puzzling mostly
blank incident report on the shooting
that listed Brianna Taylor's injuries as
despite being shot at least eight times
by police the police department has
since acknowledged the error as for what
happens next to those three officers
involved in this case well that will be
determined by the state attorney general